les éoliennes tournent et larache et
aussi la machine soulève les pieds de
pommes de terre en eau
philippe besnard est à la manoeuvre pour
effectuer un premier tri cette année la
pomme de terre a souffert de la
sécheresse et des bouts de chou pour
autant la récolte s'annonce correcte en
abondance or forcément en abondance mais
en qualité elle est superbe on a une
bonne une belle qualité
le les acheteurs sont contents de la
pomme de terre ça se vende correctement
un prix normal
transporté à la ferme les pommes de
terre passe dans un des terreurs qui
enlève la terre et les cailloux elles
sont à nouveau trier on retire les
tubercules abîmés ou coupées
or philippe qu'est-ce que darche est
aujourd'hui alors aujourd'hui c'est de
la récolte et hier c'est de la colombe à
les pommes de terre sont stockés dans le
noir à une température de 5 degrés avant
de partir pour être lavé et conditionné
puis vendus en grande surface
ces pommes de terre vont sur le marché
du frais de la bande de terre française
donc elles servent pour la segmentation
culinaire que c'est fait pour faire
d'eux des frites pour faire de la purée
pour faire dépendre de terre russe les
dons qu'elles sont utilisées suivant les
variétés donc aujourd'hui la beauce
alimentent le marché français un petit
peu à l'export mais ça sera plus tard
dans la saison avec sept cent mille
tonnes récoltées chaque année la boue
c'est la deuxième région productrice de
pommes de terre
après les hauts de france